الى باكستان حيث قتل شرطيا وبدنيا واصيب
27 معظمهم من رجال الشرطه
عاصمه اقليم بلوشستان جنوب غربي البلاد
وقد افادت مصادر المحليه بان الانفجار
ناجم عن هجوم الانتحاري تبنته حركه
الطالبات
شبه العسكريه تم استهدافهم اثناء تجمعهم
لمرافقه عاملين لنا في مجال حمله تلقيح
طبي ضد الاطفال
[موسيقى]
من اسلام اباد ينضم الينا مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر عبد الرحمن اهلا
بك ما الذي يمكن ان تضيفها الى كل هذه
المعطيات
الان الضحايا ارتفع عددهم الاجمالي الى
ثلاثه بينهم سيده من المره والطفل اضافه
بالتاكيد للرجل الشرطه الذي فارق الحياه
بسبب الانفجار الذي حتى الان تشير
المعلومات الاوليه المتوفره
للشرطه المحليه في كويتيه بان هناجم عن
عمل انتحاري لكن بالتاكيد هناك المزيد من
التحقيقات التي تجري حاليا والتي ربما
تظهر نتائجها لاحقا همم حقيقه ما حدث وكيف
تمكن هذا المهاجم ان كان بالفعل هناك
مهاجم انتحاري بسبب ما بحسب ما تعتقدها
الشرطه على الاقل الان في المعلومات
الاوليه كيف استطاع الوصول الى هذه
المجموعه من عناصر الامن الذين كانوا
يتحضرون همم التوزع ضمن مجموعات اقل عددا
لتوفير حمايه
لفرق التطعيم ضد مرض شلل الاطفال هناك
حقيقه الكثير من المؤشرات ايضا في المنطقه
ليه من البلاجان بشكل عام وعاصمته مدينه
كويتا عاده ما كانت مستهدفه من قبل
الجماعات المسلحه الانفصاليه في اقليم
بلوشستان اضافه الى ان اصلا همم المشاركون
عاده في ضمن فرق التطعيم ضد مرض شلل
الاطفال في عموم باكستان وليس فقط في
بلوشستان عاده ايضا ما يستهدفون من قبل
الكثير من المجموعات الشعبيه هنا التي
تعتقد بان مرض بان التطعيم ضد مرض شلل
الاطفال هو حقيقه يؤذي ويحد من الناس وما
الى ذلك من بعض همم الافكار المنتشره هنا
في باكستان على كل حال الحكومه الفيدراليه
هنا في العاصمه اسلام اباد امرت باجراء
تحقيق واسع لمعرفه كل التفاصيل المحيطه
بهذا الهجوم وكيف تمكن هذا المهاجم ان كان
بالفعل هناك مهاجم كيف يتمكن من الوصول
الى هذه المجموعه من قوات الامن وكيف
استطاع التنفيذ هذا الهجوم نحن بانتظار
حقيقه همم التحقيقات المستمره حتى الان
لمعرفه كل التفاصيل المحيطه بهذا الهجوم
عبد الرحمن مطر كنت معنا من اسلام اباد
شكرا لك